okay so let's get started
so um
I think last time what we are left was
um
[Music]
I think we covered the weaker
generalization belt
um and then today we are going to
provide a stronger organization about
uh for the new network
let me just double check whether I
sorry I think some high
if I was confused where I'm
okay cool yeah okay yeah so last time
what we did was that we had this
[Music]
um
standardization bound of uh of the form
that you have something like something
in the square root and in the
denominator and
and today we are going to remove that
script and
um you know not exactly by just
improving the bound we also have to kind
of like somewhat change the hypothesis
class so that's the that's the first
part of the lecture and then we are
going to talk about
um today we're going to talk about
stronger so first we talk about stronger
version and then we talk about some
connections
to Kernel method
and then we will talk about uh even
stronger bonds um for a multiple layer
in your networks and that requires some
preparation
um with some techniques and we'll talk
about those techniques if we have time
today otherwise we'll talk about those
next week
okay so just to briefly review the setup
so the setup was that we have some Theta
which is consists of
two layers and the first layer is
uh I think this is called second layer
which is the vector W and the first
layer is a matrix that Maps Dimension B
to Dimension n and our model is
something like
double transpose V of u x
and the fee is element wise relu
and
so last time what we heard was that we
have this generalization bound
of the form that this rather marker
complexity
of H is bounded by something like 2
times BW
b u times c squared n Over N where H is
defined to be something like
where yours you restricted two Norm of w
to be BW
and you restricted the max
to Norm of UI to be
bu
and that's the hypothesis class and in
some sense
if you I guess we discussed this a
little bit in the in the class you know
um so and also I think somebody asked
this question you see in some sense
there's a scaling environment because
you can so Alpha times w
over Alpha U would be the same model as
W Times U right so just because you can
scale the first layer by Alpha and then
you down scale the second layer back one
over Alpha if Alpha is bigger than zero
so that means that you can also kind of
change this bound a little bit and re
rewrite it as something like basically
you can say that roughly speaking the
generalization our
is something like bonded by all of
square root n Over N oh sorry this is
square rooting over square root n times
the norm of w
times the max I
the max of the two normal view right
this is kind of the intuitive way to
think about this
so
um so so today we're going to have a
stronger bond that doesn't have the
script on here but we'll have some
slightly different terms here in terms
of how do you measure the complexity of
w and the complexity of E
Okay so
so here is a refined Bond let me Define
this let me say the theorem first
so the theorem is that we Define this
complex measure that's called C of theta
this complex measure is defined to be
the sum of
the absolute value W J times
the true Norm of EU J and you take a sum
over J
and correspondingly given this hypo
complex match you can Define the
corresponding hypothesis class
which is the family of functions with
bonded
complexity something like 1 by B
and also we assume that
the norm of x i is less than C
for every I
know that here actually we have a
stronger Assumption of data because
before we assume the average of the norm
is less than C
uh other or the average of the square
Norm is less than c squared now we
assume each data point is less than C
this is just the technicality in some
sense
um and with all of this then we can
prove that the rather marker complexity
of H is divided by 2 times B times C
over square root
okay so maybe let me first start with
some interpretation of this theorem and
see why this is an interesting one to
prove and they are the proof so a few
remarks the first one is that why this
is you know better uh than before right
so I'm claiming that this is strictly
better
uh
than before
um at least in the following sense
um so if you really you know I guess um
um so the way that I compare them is the
following so before what we had was that
so before what we had was that this
generalization is something like square
root n over squared n times this
complexity something like
two Norm of W Times the this one as we
said
that's kind of the intuitive thinking
about it if you assume the the C is a
constant C is just something about the
data which then we change as we change
the com the the hypothesis class is
really something like a constant
um and and now you can basically think
of this new bound as people of one over
square root 10 times B which is the
capital B the capital B is basically sum
of w j times
uj2 not right so basically I'm
the way I'm comparing it doesn't mean is
that I'm comparing these two quantities
and I claim that the second quantity is
strictly smaller than the first quantity
and the reason is just that uh if you do
some simple
in the call okay you can see that this
is
less than
um
so you first do a closet shorts you say
this is less than sum of w j Square half
and sum of
UJ two Norm Square to the power of half
and then the first term becomes two Norm
of w
and the second term
is you can Bond each of them by the max
so you get
M times Max J
u j two Norm square a half
so what you got is square root n times
W two naught times Max
say
u j to know
so so this is a in this size this is a
circle better amount and you know they
could be the same you know if your WG
and UJ makes all of these inequalities
exactly equal but in other cases it
won't and in some sense you can see one
of the intuition here is that this new
complex measure so another thing is that
this new complexity measure
see Theta captures the invariance
captures the scaling environments better
or what do I mean by that so so what I
mean is that so what I mentioned I
mentioned the following scaling
environments right so if you have W and
u
this is equival equivalent to
Alpha W over Alpha U right this is
because like the the value is scaling
environment and you can do this but
actually you have a lot more scaling
environments you can scale actually each
pairs of neurons you know in this way so
what you really have is that this is
actually equivalent to you can
scale each wi to something like WJ
you skill each of these um
uh
the chase coordinates by Alpha G and you
scale correspondingly of one over Alpha
J times u j
and you do this for different scalar for
every WG and UG and this is still the
same
right just because you know the sum of
WJ
value
UJ transpose X is the same as
Alpha jwj view of
1 over Alpha j u j x for any u j for any
scaling that is positive
right so and you can see that if you
consider this kind of environment still
this complex measure is the same right
so the complexity measure is
is really environment
to the scaling here because if you
change WJ and UJ accordingly you don't
change the complexity which
is to some extent it seems to be a good
thing to have right so
so it's so but before the the complex
measure doesn't have this property right
so if you look at this complex dimension
if you scale each of the WJ
by a different scalar and you skate each
of the user by different scalar you
wouldn't this number would change
sure
right
uh
right so so you are saying that this
okay yes so yes so this one you you do
make a stronger assumption to do this
problem
sorry okay
yes
uh sorry what was the question maybe I
didn't answer
so so yeah but I think I I I'm guessing
what you are saying is that before the
the the condition was something like
[Music]
I think it's one over n times sum of x i
two Norm square root is less than six
that was in the previous theorem I think
or or something like or maybe that was
uh in the previous team we did this
is less than c squared right so so
indeed this is so the new condition is
stronger than old ones because the this
one implies the automatic right so
um yeah so I'm assuming that suppose you
say this is not a problem like you just
you just live with the stronger
assumption then our bound is strictly
better in some sense this assumption X
is a little bit less important to some
extent because
for example you know if anywhere your
data satisfies the stronger assumption
that is less important right so
so
um
yeah but you are right that the data
assumption is a little bit different but
I don't think it's uh it matters that
much
um
right right that's true that that's
definitely true
um or you can choose the right C uh so
um but I guess I think the question was
more about comparing the two theorems
you know you know if you normalize key
or maybe you should normalize there so
so what's the fire comparison
um
cool so so this is one thing one other
thing about this complex measure in some
sense like uh this complex measure is a
little bit more environment to the to at
least the trivial environments in the
matchwork so
um and also the the bound is better and
also another thing that we have about
nothing about this is that
um about this theorem is that if you
have M goes to Infinity
at least you get you know a stronger or
equally or a stronger or equivalent uh
theorem so the theorem
is stronger
so what what do I mean by that so let me
let me explain this so suppose you look
at the dependency on N right so this
whole theorem depends on M implicitly
somewhere I didn't specify that but now
let's make it more expressive let's say
say hm is this complexity in the same
thing right so uh where you you have M
neurons
and also C Theta is less than b
all right so forever M our theorem
applies so but I'm now I'm just making a
dependency on I'm a little bit more
explicit
and you know that hm is a subset of hm
plus one
in in verses in the sense that you know
if you have a function that is in hm
it can always you know either fake
neural or zero dummy neural to make an H
M plus one register so any
I've stated in hm you can either
a dummy
new room
so meaning that you make W plus 1 0 and
you
M plus one zero
and then you can extend this function so
that it becomes in hm password
so so H M plus 1 is always a strong it's
a bigger family of functions than HR so
so so that's what that's why you have a
stroke by the bond then depend on F
right like you have the same
rather work complexity for everyone so
in some sense your your bound would be
stronger for bigger
so so the strongest theorem would be you
just applied for H Infinity
so so and and that's actually in some
sense the fundamental reason why uh
later you see that you know you're gonna
have a generalization Bond at least a
generalization bond that is decreasing
as M goes to Infinity so
um
and that's another nice property of this
complex semester and also another small
remark is that there's something called
personal
um if you don't haven't heard of it you
know probably doesn't matter this is um
um this is a complex semester that
people in parallel that people proposed
and people evaluate that
people found that this is correlated
with the the
um the the real generalization bound
empirically and and this is very closely
related to the definition of c Theta
here so in some sense what you kind of
see
of the parts Norm is trying to say that
you look at all the parts from the input
to the output and you look at the total
kind of norms of all the process and in
some sense this is kind of like that you
know it's not exactly the same depending
on which version of the Platinum but
but kind of like the way you think about
this is that
you look at the input X and
um so this is WJ and and these things is
UJ
so in some sense you you look at the so
every Parts matters right so that's why
you look at WJ times u j first and then
you take this up instead of letting you
look at each layer first and then you
multiply
um
yeah if you haven't heard of the partner
what I said probably wouldn't be
wouldn't make that much sense like uh
but if you have heard of it probably you
can see the connection this is not super
important this is just a something
people have you know empirically studied
um
all right so uh we'll talk about more
implications of the theorem um later but
before that let me prove the Improvement
any questions so far
so how do we prove this so you can see
that the the kind of one of the main
point in the proof is that you're able
to kind of like change the scaling in
the right way because you want to
capture the scaling environments you
don't want to peel off so before what we
did was that we tried to remove the w
first and then we remove the EU right
you you have a soup over W and U you
somehow remove each of them sequentially
and now the the thing is that you still
do the same thing but you want to remove
them
um
sequentially as well but you want to
first rescale things first and then
remove them so that you can eventually
get the right kind of scaling
environment I'm not sure about this big
size stacker we can you see like more
clearly in the proof so
so first of all let's define this Vector
U let's define U Bar to be the
normalized version for you
so and then let's start
with the derivation
so what we have is that the writer
marker complexity is something like this
I put one moreover in front just to make
it easier so you have this is the
definition
and I guess
we do the usual thing
the first steps the first two steps are
just
plugging in the definition
I
and now we want to firstly rescue W and
U before we take the soup
so what we do is that we
write this as
WJ
uj2 Norm so and then we in insert the
the fee we use UJ bar transpose x i
right so in some sense you you put the
norm of UJ outside of the fee
and the normal view J is a positive
number so you can put it out outside of
the fee
um and
sorry I have a little bit of trouble
reading this
um but I think I kind of remember what
oh okay like there's a page segment so
that I couldn't read what's my notes
were
um anyway so
um so you rearrange this a little bit so
in some sense we treat this WJ times uj2
Norm as our owj and we want to kind of
remove that first
that's kind of and also you can see that
this one is something that shows up in
the complexity measure the complex
measure is basically the sum of this is
less than V right the complex measure is
really just the sum of wjuj2 to not
right so you have shift over Theta
and you
uh I guess rewrite this you change this
the order of the summation so that
it's clearer that
of this times
u j f u j bar transpose x i
and here I guess let's specify what the
constraint of theta is the constraint of
theta is that c Theta is less than b
which means that this wju J2 Norm is
less than b right so the constraint is
really just saying that the sum of WJ
uj2
is less than is less than b
and now you can see that the sum of
these quantities is less than b but we
care about the weighted result right so
we wait the each of the coin is by
something and then you take this up
sorry
this is the the best
the best
um this is a problem when you derive
things on the Fly just this particular
line couldn't really find my nose so so
I'm improvising okay
um
thanks
um so and then let's uh okay so we know
that the sum of wju J2 is less than b so
that means that you can use the inner
quality here so you say that you
so you
um
I guess maybe maybe let me just have a
so this is like basically you're
applying this
aibi is specialized that you don't know
the sub in AI times the max of EI
this is what we are applying actually I
probably should use J just to be more
consistent with
so this is J from one to n and this is J
from 1 to m a j
PJ and AJ corresponds to
wjuj turn on and B J corresponds to this
quantity
right it's absolutely what I'm doing so
if you
live in this then you get
basically the sum of AJ
the sum of
WJ
uj2 Norm J from 1 to n times the max
over J
right so in some sense this is a holder
in the quality right so like the inner
product of A and B is less than the one
Norm of a and the infinite number of b
um
and then this quantity now we got this
separate one this is less than b right
so then this is less than one over n
times
Sigma
times B times soup over Theta
Max J
sum of Sigma i v u j bar transpose x y
and now this if you carefully compare
this with what we had before this should
look somewhat similar familiar because
in some sense we
we achieve almost the same things as we
have done before we
we remove the influence of w and we
won't have something about you and here
what you have about you doesn't have the
scale anymore you only have UJ barf
so
so basically now what you can do is that
you can say that
um so so from here is basically the same
thing as the previous proof
um let me try to repeat a few steps so I
guess one thing you can do is that you
realize that this Max over J is not
doing really much so what you can do is
that you can replace this by Max over U
Bar where the norm of U Bar is one
and some
Sigma I
V U Bar transpose XL
so that's one thing we can do
sure that's that's good point so I
should have reps value so
I think I should have right here
and I should have it here and I still
should have it here
X
yeah thanks for catching all of this
issues so and then this I guess
you probably also remember there's a
step I skipped before where I removed
the apps value by paying a factor two
so you can do it you can this less than
this soup
right and there was uh all of these are
almost the same as you know it's exactly
the same as before and now you can pee
off the you can remove the fee by the
the the the
lipstick compensation number or the
telegram number
so you can
get rid of the fee
so this is Tyler ground timer
and then you can
then this becomes the complexity of the
linear model and you do some thing and
then you can get the same thing like 2B
C over square rooted
where the C comes from the
comes from the norm of the X star
right so
Yeah so basically
from
basically from after here these are so
this part
the same as before
um I guess there's a small difference
which is that
the U Bar now is normalized to Norm one
right so so you just have a so that's
why you don't catch up so before like if
you look at the the proof before what
happens is that you don't have the you
have some other control View Bar it
controls the U you you know the norm of
you use the SMB and now you know the
normal View Bar is less than one so
that's why you don't have the bu show up
in the final bound because the normal
view R is less than one
so so in some sense this is just almost
the same proof which the only difference
is that you somehow remove the scaling
of U First
you put the scaling of you actively in
the in the W so that you can
organize this a little bit better
any questions
correct so I think next let me talk
about some of the the kind of like the
implications
of the of the theory here some of them
are kind of like interesting so
I think one thing is that if you believe
in a theory then what directly we should
do is that
this is not what people do in practice
but I would argue this this is also
close to what people do in the practice
um but if you just believe in a theory
what you probably would do is you want
to define the following Max Martin
solution right you want to do the max
margin on the minimum Norm solution so I
guess you can do
maybe the pro either do program one
where you minimize the complexity of C
Theta
and with the constraint that the margin
is larger than what
right
the why we care about the margin we call
that you know all of this depends on the
margin eventually because you know
eventually your generalization error
will be the complexity of the margin
or alternatively
I think these are exactly equivalent
so you can you can say that you you
maximize the margin
and with the constraint that
uh your complexity is less than one
so let's call this program two and we
can probably find this here
I'm started I guess I probably don't
have to define null so you can do these
two programs right so and these two
programs the reason why uh you you want
this program is because your
generalization are rebound
will be something like
the generalization error will be
something like iOS data
will be less than I would say the Hat
will be less than so you said I had over
Gamma mean
Theta hat
over scrotum
plus lower the terms
right this is the using the general
Machinery that we had right so so you
have one over Square rooting so like you
basically have they write the marker
complexity this is the rather micro
complexity
and sorry I mean
this part is the brother marker
complexity this corresponds to the
rather macro complexity
of H and this is the margin
um right so that's what we got from the
modern Theory
easy to see
something
I think
depending on
I think you are basically right
um but I think I would say this is
already something
like we already achieved something
because
this I think maybe the right way to
think about this is that
you compare these two in a two
two things right so in the very idealist
takeaway right so for all the wgs are
the same all the UJS are the same then
these two bonds are just the same so
then you are right you are just folding
you are just changing your form of your
bone and nothing really changed right
you somehow fold the square root and
somewhere but the
the thing is that this is not tight
always and and you probably shouldn't
expect it to be tight it's not it
shouldn't be the case that all the wjs
and UJS are the same you probably should
have a detailing wjas you have more and
more neurons you're going to have
smaller and smaller WJ
um
just be you know like there's no way
that this is tied for all I'm right so
like it can be tied for all that for one
eye but if you add more neurons it
wouldn't be touched so so the typical
thing would be that
you have more eyes you have more and
more neurons these neurons probably
should you know have smaller and smaller
Norm
um because they are capturing like you
know more and more kind of complex you
know subtleties in your function Club
you know in your ground shoes function
right so so so so basically I'm saying
that this this inequality wouldn't be
tight uh in the in the in the idealistic
in the in the ground choose function for
example
right so
um yeah but but from a very technical
point of view I think that's the only we
only did a very small trick to to change
the form
yeah I think you can say that in some
sense yes
uh
or at least the other bound would be
yeah I guess depending on how you think
about it this yeah
um but I think the way I think about
this that is really just okay the way I
think about it is that these two bonds
are exactly the same when all the wgs
and UJS are the same like they are all
for example constant or something like
that or maybe all one over Square time
so then you don't get anything from this
right so
um but uh but it will be much different
if you want to find the function where
your WJ and UJ goes to zero gradually as
you have more money neurons
okay so
um
right okay so going back to the
transition Bond so so I think the
generalization bond in some sense
motivates the the use of this kind of
like Max modern solution or the minimum
Norm solution just because
eventually your rather markup complexity
depends on the complexity of the the
model and and you also have the margin
term from the from the margin part from
the last part
so and one of the interesting thing is
that this quantity if you think about
this quantity
and this quality can you can show this
is not increasing as I'm goes to
Infinity
so and the reason is actually pretty
simple so but maybe let me write down
just to be to to be clear about what I
really mean so let's say let's use it I
had M to be the minimizer
of uh of say program one
right so and I'm is to in to index which
how many neurons you are using
so for every time you have a minimizer
and you can Define gamma M Star to be
um to be the the solution of the to be
the corresponding margin right you can
Define gamma M Star to be the
the margin with the constraints that D
Theta is
so let's say Define this vehicle M Star
right so
by the way I think I'm
I think I want to Define this to be two
so let's let's let's mostly use two as
my as our main thing like a this is a
little bit Title Here
Okay so
um so suppose you solve this program too
and you get this Max modern solution
right so and then
uh so your bound so this means that
the bound
is
C Theta Hide N over gamma mean
say that I had M over square root n and
because we normalize the C the
complexity to be one so this is really
one over gamma M Star Times Square
rooted
right this is the generation box so
basically whether this bond is better or
not depends on whether gamma M Star
is increasing or decreasing
and and interestingly the gamma star
is increasing
this is a
and this is in some sense of almost bad
definition why this is because if you
think about what the gamma star M Star
means it means that the maximum margin
you can achieve when you restrict your
complexity to be less than what
right and I also use M neurons and the
thing is that when you have more neurons
at least you would achieve the same
margin you shouldn't be worse just
because the only like right so with more
neurons
you never get worse
can at least achieve the same margin by
adding just the dummy neuron as kind of
exactly the same argument as I had right
at least
achieve the same margin
because you've just either done in your
room and it doesn't change the
functionality it doesn't change the
complexity it doesn't change the margin
it's just everything is the same but
having more neurons give you additional
flexibility you could possibly kind of
like change your neurons a little bit
more cleverly instead of just adding a
dummy neuron that's by your margin
adding one more neuron will potentially
make a margin bigger
so so at least you know you never get
the margin smaller by adding neurons
so so that means that this Bond can
decrease as an uh goes to Infinity
um at least it's not increasing as n
goes to Infinity
so so in some sense this is kind of like
the nice thing about this compared to
other bonds where you have explicit
dependency on and if you have an
explicit dependency on M at least you
know if you just look at it it wouldn't
you wouldn't be able to argue that this
bond is better so so now you can say
this one is bad better as M goes to
Infinity of course this doesn't really
say
this doesn't address everything because
this is just the upper bound right it's
not like you are saying that the actual
generalization error is decreasing as M
goes to Infinity that would be the ideal
theorem you want to prove right that's
that would match exactly the
the the plus I showed last time where
you have more neurons and you your bad
your accuracy is improving how your your
arrow is decreasing right so so here
you're only talking about bonds right so
if the bond is loose then
um it's unclear whether this
decreasingly M thing is is really a big
deal
um and that's that's indeed true so but
I think this is a you know in some sense
this is a starting point right so if
your bond is increasing M that is
completely useless right your bond is
decreasing um that doesn't really mean
that it's it's super powerful but at
least that's a good sign to have right
that's a that's a good thing to have
uh and and in some sense it's really
very it's really hard to capture the
exact
uh
test error so if you really want to say
that the exact test error or the
generalization error is decreasingly and
that's basically the only thing you can
do is with uh with linear model at least
so far the only techniques I know is
that you just literally compute exactly
what the test error is on linear model
you can do the analytical derivation
using linear algebra to simplify them
and in certain cases you can you can
show indeed the uh the average decrease
as I'm goes to inflated this is uh this
is actually a pretty
um um
popular
uh Direction in the last few years like
people have done this for
various kind of linear models but
basically only recipient to linear
models
um
right so so here you know we want to
work with right work so so we have to
kind of somehow live with a weaker
result you only say that the bond is
decreasing but not actual error is
decreasing
Okay so
I guess the next thing I want to say is
that
um is actually okay another thing that
is this is different from this program
well too they are still different from
what you do in practice right you
probably don't do exactly this
complexity measure nobody regulates it
like that probably somebody tried they
probably wouldn't make a difference
um and and here what I'm going to say is
that actually it's interesting that this
complex measure
this complex measure is definitely
different from L2 complex measure right
but once you minimize the complex
measure is this you get the same effect
as minimizing L2 that's all minimizing
L2 is the same as minimizing this uh
maybe let me let me just clarify what
what does that mean so basically my my
main point here is that if you maximize
margins
uh
so sorry you can so so you can so can be
done
by
minimizing across entropy laws
the one that with L2 regularization
so here I have two things one is I'm
using cross Enterprise I'm using L2
regularization I'll do it do one of them
um as that so at the first I'm going to
first use L2 organization instead of the
complex mesh I defined and I'm going to
say that it's actually doing the same
thing so here's this first timer
so so suppose you consider
the one we have considered right so
let's call this J1 which is
you minimize the complexity with the
constraint that the margin is
larger than one by the way I I keep
changing the sometimes I'm minimizing
the complexity with the margins and one
sometimes times minimizing the margin
with the complexities less than one
it's the somehow yeah I probably should
make a move all consistent but just in
my mind they are always the same so
sometimes I forgot to sorry I should
probably just keep keep a single version
of it but but the other thing they are
just the like a equivalent because
um yeah
um yeah so anyway so so here I'm
minimize the complexity with the margins
larger than one and I'm claiming that if
you look at another one which is you
minimize the L2
thing the L2 Norm
and with the constraint that
the margin is larger than what
so these two
are the same
so obviously these two functions are not
the same right these two complex
measures are not the same but if you
minimize the complexity the extreme
opponent actually turns out to be the
same
which is kind of interesting
um and the proof is like false so
um
I think at least one thing you know is
that
uh the the regular the Iota
regularization what is that this is also
regularization is the sum of the squares
of all the parameters which is sum of WJ
square plus sum of u j to Norm Square
and you can show that this is larger
than the complex measure we have defined
because you can use the amgm so you can
say this is WJ square plus
u j two Norm square and use
I think this is called AMG I mean
inequality of
you know for me everything is caution
sure so it's just inequality so but
anyway so you get WJ times
uj2 Norm
times two
and you cancel these two so this is B
Theta
right so so you're so you are minimizing
so in J2 the program J2 you are
minimizing a larger complexity measure
but I guess you know the intuition is
that even though you're minimizing a
larger complex measure but when you
uh the extremal point
actually will make these two things the
same so the intuition is that
the extremal point
should satisfy
should satisfy W J is equals to u j
even you are when you are minimizing the
L2 regularization
right so and if that's the suppose
that's the case then you can kind of
believe that these two things are the
same because when I'm minimizing the L2
regularization if the extreme point is
satisfies this then I for this case if
this is true then C Theta is the same as
the L2 so then you are not really doing
anything different so that's kind of the
intuition
um if you really want to prove this kind
of formally I guess the simplest way to
prove this is the
following
so so so you you you say that I guess
this implies that J2 is lower than J1
and you want to use the institution
intuition to show that J1 is bigger than
J2 instead is larger than 22 as well so
what we do is that we say that
data
in the minimizer
of one
of J1
maybe let's call this
I think let's call this uh maybe
three and this is four
so
is that a good number that's probably
not a good number let's call this
P1 and P2
so minimizer of P1
and then what you do is you construct
so you get a Theta that is the minimizer
of the first one and you want to
construct a Theta Prime which
is
uh it's very good on the
um
on the stack in terms of the second
program so you construct consider Prime
and what you do is that you say I'm
going to take WJ Prime to be the
renormalized version
of the of WJ and UJ from
again to be the really normalized
version of ug
and then you can verify that because I'm
just a change in the scaling UJ
times Phi of WJ transpose X is the same
as
sorry WJ times V of u j transpose X is
the same as before
and also WJ
in terms of the complexity measure they
are also the same
after doing this transformation
okay and and this means that c Theta
it's the same as C Theta Prime and F
Theta is the same as F0 Prime so the
functionality and the complex measure
didn't change
and
and what's interesting is that for Theta
Prime
V sub Prime is also equals to
the L2 Norm because
my construction okay why I'm doing this
construction I'm doing this construction
because I wanted WJ
it to be equals to the norm of u j
this is why I choose this uh scale by
the way I think this should be like this
oh sorry
wait am I right oh no it's like this all
right so we can verify WJ is the same as
the usage
this right so because
in you know this is actually my design
in some sense like you can verify this
you know like but but this is like you
know if if this is true I should change
my design to make a two but that's the
that's the point so
um
so that means that so what does this
mean this means that
Prime satisfies
constraint
of so all of this means that the series
Prime constraints of P2
so that means that
C Theta Prime is less than
is so it's bigger than J2
right and
C to the prime is equals to
and Theta the prime
is equals to a half Theta Prime
square is equals to a half
sorry C to the prime
is equals to
okay
what is this equal to this is equals to
let's see what's going on here
then
I want to show that Theta Prime is
equals to J1 this is because
right this is this is just because Theta
Prime is equals to C Theta which is
equals to J1
okay
I didn't change the complex measure
because I'm just really scaling so
that's why J1 is bigger than J2
and before you get J2 is bigger than 31
so that's why
J2 and J1 that's it
yeah actually I was a little hesitated I
was a little bit hesitant whether I
should show this proof or the a more
intuitive or another version which is
actually intellectuals in the lecture
notes there's a slightly different way
to prove the same thing uh at the end of
the everything is relatively simple it's
not nothing really hard
um so this proof is very easy to verify
and the other proof is kind of like in
some sense covers the intuition
intuition is really just what like what
I said at the extreme point this I know
with WJ and UJ two Norm has to be the
same so this two complex measures are
not different
so that's the that's the main intuition
so the prime satisfies the constraint P2
so the constraint is only about the
margin right so the margin
uh is only about the functionality of
this model right so if you predict the
same thing your margin will be the same
right so Theta parameters data have the
same functionality because you only
rebalance the the scale right you just
multiply WJ by something on
divide the use it by something else so
so the functionality is maintained so
that's why the margins that's it
in the why there is no yeah
so here
this is the equality
oh sorry sorry sorry not bad
why this is because this is in
accordance
[Music]
um
okay great so
okay so the first thing okay so the
first level we have so okay what we have
done we're basically are saying that if
you minimize the L2 Norm it's the same
as minimizing this
um complex measure okay and we also
wanted to do the cross entropy and this
is something I'm not going to prove but
I'm just going to stay alive stay the
dilemma and if you're interested you can
read a
um with a paper about it like you know
the proof is actually relatively simple
but I think uh we'll probably have time
today to do that
um so so the Lemma too is that if you
consider
a regularized
cross entropy laws
and something like L height Lambda Theta
which is equals to one over n
um
I guess in this lecture this is the
first time I have ever talked about what
cross entropy loss but I I assume that
you some would know what they are right
this is the the laws for the logistic
regression right you have more I times F
Theta x i
um so this is your input and the loss is
the log of one so the loss in some sense
is really
log one plus exponential minus t this is
the logistic loss
and you you add some Lambda
times L2 regularization
suppose you do this and
and let's say that
title of the hat with a minimizer
I'm going to claim that for small enough
Lambda Federal height Lambda is
basically doing the same thing as the
max modern solution
um but there is a small thing that I I
have to deal with it which is that what
is the norm right because the max
marginal thing is is you need a you need
a norm you need a
basically you need to care about the
ratio between the margin and the and the
norm so so that's why my statement is
that
uh
[Applause]
okay I don't know why
okay yeah so then
okay it's my statement is something
about this it's like this so basically
you can say that if Lambda goes to 0 for
small is not enough Lambda
then
the norm versus the margin
will goes to
J1
J1 which was defined to be
the max the the minimum Norm solution
right
this is just a I'm recalling the
definition so basically you are
converging to the max modern solution or
the minimum Norm solution up to a
scaling because here I'm looking at the
ratio so this when you have a small a
very small uh Theta you uh
sorry when you have this very small
Lambda your Norm of theta would be
something actually pretty big that's
because your organization is too weak so
you you are going to get very big thumb
solution but if you normalize the norm
with the margin then you you found that
this is actually the max modern solution
um I'm not gonna prove this I guess if
you're interested this is a theorem 4.2
of a paper I wrote
um with
collaborators
um and actually this theorem is actually
very simple like um
um um and actually it works for not only
the L2 regularization it works for
almost all homogeneous or like almost
all regularizations you can think of so
so the gist is basically saying that if
you care about the max margin uh
solution with respect to certain complex
measure right so if the complex measure
could be L2 in this case it could be
something else
like here it could be anything right so
one way to achieve it is that you just
add a very weak regularization in your
course entropy loss and that will give
you the maximum solution
okay
any questions
[Music]
yeah so the general kind of like the
gist is that suppose you care about the
max modern solution right but maximum
resolution requires a complex measure
right you need to say I'm minimizing the
norm such a norm with the margin slogan
well I'm maximize the margin with some
constraints right there's a norm right
so or there's a complex measure so if
you want to get the maximum resolution
you just put a complex mesh in the
uh here
right so and with a small enough Lambda
then and you have cross entropy laws and
then
the solution this will will give you the
maximizing solution
uh of course you can look for the
maximum solution you know just directly
by solving the program but you can also
do it like this way and this is
something that seems to be more
um typical like at least this is what
people do in paracord all the time in
some sense right in some sense this is
just linking
um what people do in particularly with
the maximal resolution which is not what
people do that typically in deep
learning
um
right but but there is a but the caveat
here like if you care about the broader
the interpretation the caveat here is
you need a longer to be very small so
basically this is saying that if you use
a very small Lambda you get a maximum
resolution but the empirical actually
you don't use that small amount you
actually use something bigger than
uh bigger than this infinitesimal small
Lambda so so empirical you probably
wouldn't get exactly Max minus solution
you're gonna get something similar to it
but not exactly the same
and actually it's kind of interesting
that like I guess probably for cs29
um like you have learned like a Max
marketing solution right so it sounds
like the
before deep learning that's the that's
the right thing to do right like but
even like even you look at linear models
it's never at least I haven't seen I'm
not I'm not a like a practitioner I do a
lot of theory but when I do experiments
I've never seen that
next modern solution is the best for
leading model
somehow
it's it's like when you use a very small
Lambda you do get maximum resolution but
if you use bigger longer sometimes it's
a little better
so so I think Max smarter switching some
steps is just a theoretic approximation
of what people really do in practice
um
all right so let me see
so the next part I'm trying to I'm
trying to connect this uh this deep
learning thing this this deep learning
not very deep like two layer not working
with the the so-called L1 xpn
this is also kind of like a I think
people
um like the exact kind of like a
uh thing is in my paper as well like but
it's only a like a three paragraphs like
in appendix
um and we are we are not really
inventing it we we just uh
in some sense said something that people
already knew like implicitly we thought
that it's useful to write it down
um so so so so so the so the general
thing is that you want to say what we're
going to claim is the following so we're
going to claim that this is really doing
uh what you might work is doing with
this two layer Network and the maximizer
solution it's really just doing
something like L1 svr uh in some future
in some kind of feature space
um so but let me explain you know
uh I guess I haven't defined what L1 SPM
is right so you're probably familiar
with SVN that's the so-called L2 version
of the sphere so here you are going to
have a slightly different version of XVM
so
um the the
the kind of the the idea is that first
of all let's look at infinite number of
neurons
because we have claimed that you know
more neurons is always better so why not
think about infinite number of neurons
and let's see what infinite number of
neurons you will do for us right so you
look at the max margin when you have
infinite of neurons this is the largest
possible margin you can achieve uh with
even even number of neurons and suppose
this is achieved
by
E1
so and so forth
you need infant number of neurons
probably
so many neurons
actually this you can achieve this
without number even number of neurons
you can achieve it with I think n plus
one neurons any number of data points so
um but but let's say you have infinite
number of neurons just like basically
basically infinite is not very different
from n plus one neurons as long as you
have more than M plus by neurons you
don't really get anything more uh from
this so
um and let's again U Bar is the
normalization of U
so I think we have kind of play with
this like a lot of times right this is
equivalent
to W1
U1
two Norm U1 bar so and so forth right
this is uh what we have let's call this
setup setup
I think I'll call you serial killer in
this case and I call this one W12
okay so we have kind of like uh then
it's really scaling a lot of times and
we know that if you rescale this you
don't change the complex measure and and
here the complex measure is
right the wju J2 norm and this is the
just the W J tilde
absolute value so this is the one Norm
of WJ W tilde
so so that that's where the one now I'm
coming to play
so basically the idea is that
after you change this Viewpoint
basically you just view W1 W1 tilde as
the variable
and then you are doing some kind of like
sparse linear regression of sparse
sphere
so
um so formally what you can do is that
you can say you can pretend
um
so every
you in the
sphere on a sphere as T minus one is the
dimensional sphere
so you pretends every u in the sphere
shows up
in a collection of u-bars
right once you pretend that ever you and
why this is possible this is just
because adding more neurons is never a
bad thing but you add a lot of neurons
to the to the uis and you just set those
corresponding
this is just because you can add neuros
at you you J
and zero right you you just add these
things it never it never change anything
right if you don't see any neurons in
this collection you just add
this neural into the collection and you
added zero as the coefficient it doesn't
change the functionality it doesn't
change the complex measure
so that's why you can pretend that the
collection of E1 up to u u n and
I guess there is also more you have
infinite of this
it's really just a collection of all the
possible
unit Norm Vector on the chere
that doesn't really change anything
and and once you have that then so once
you pretend that this UJ bar is just a
equals to sd-1 then you can take a
continuous perspective you can say that
this F Theta Q the X
is really something like sum of right if
you write the
discrete version you got this but you
can say this is
you can think of this as a continuous
version
We Are Forever every U Bar you have a w
and you are integrating over all the
u-bar
I'm not sure whether this makes any
sense
um this is the
the simplest way that I came up with to
defend this without
talking about uh what's up
at least you know this is one way that I
came up to expand this without too much
Dragon
um but I
of course I don't know whether this
works for everyone
um again in the lecture notes there is a
slight different way to to to introduce
this
which requires a bit more drug and I
don't know
um any questions
oh sorry my bad one writing Sigma here
see yeah
sorry sorry
uh okay
uh
yeah feel free
oops
right okay yeah can I have ankle so the
question is whether we can have anchor
phone number of neurons
um
um
here this is not soup
like
this is just a concept or like a like
for example
the same question could you could ask
the same question about why you can when
you define the integral actually you are
using the countable number of
these kind of decisions and you take the
limit you can still get something
uncomfortable so so this is kind of the
same thing it's it's yeah and also in
some sense eventually this thing
is kind of like just a language in some
sense it's not really like you implement
the integral
in in the
uh in practice so yeah
doesn't make some sense okay so and and
basically I think if you if you see this
this is kind of like what you can the
way you can view this is that you can
see this is a WTO the inner product with
a fee
and a fee X is a universal
feature map
so so basically you think of this each
of this is a feature this is a feature
and this is like the coefficient
um in front of the feature and this
feature is a is a now the feature is a
the difference between now the
difference here is that this feature is
a predefined feature it's no longer
something learned because you have all
the possible U Bar in this world in your
feature set so so basically you can view
this this V ax is really just a this
gigantic feature
okay fee feature Vector where you have
all the possible
u-bars you know feature set
so and WTO is the coefficient in front
of feature
so so basically if you
if you kind of like a text cs209 then
this is the feature in the kernel part
and this is the
Theta
or the the weight vector or the
parameters uh in front of features so
now it's a linear function in the
feature uh in the features
so
um so but the the thing is that the
complexity measure corresponds to as we
argue with corresponds to W tilde one
Norm
but now two not
so so this is a
so this is why the max margin
with you know
this field Theta is less than one
corresponds to
Max margin
with
this L1 on Max margin
so basically you can think of this as
the so the corresponding questions you
are maximizing the margin the margin is
the same so w tilde v x i
take the mean over I
and Max over W2 though and with the
constraint that
the one Norm is less than one
and this is called L1 svm
with
feature
fee
so so on the difference from the svm you
learned in the for example cs209 would
be that this is one North but not two
naught
so so it's not doing just a simple
kernel sphere it's doing something uh
different from that and the interesting
thing is that the L1 SPM is actually not
implementable
with infinite features
it's not implementable
so
like a when you take a cs29 one of the
message we had is that when you use the
Kernel check you can actually work with
infant dimensional feature
because you can you can change
everything depends on the Kernel the
inner product of the features so you
don't really care about dimensionality
of the features you can work with
infinite dimensional feature but here
you don't have that Kernel check anymore
so if you have the L1 constant the
kernel trick doesn't apply uh this the
final solution is not just the function
of the inner product of the features
um so so you cannot apply the kernel
trick so that's why you cannot
implemented with the
um
like where's the chronologic so so so
this this is so so this part is purely
for understanding this is saying that
okay new network is doing something more
than what you can do with kernel because
now you are you are effectively doing an
L1 version of the kernel problem which
was not able to do which is something
you are not able to do with the the
standard Kernel check you have to use
the new network to achieve the same
thing
uh we didn't yeah we didn't prove that
lyx VM is not implementable
um but I think the how do I say this
uh I guess you know how do you prove
that it's not implementable like you
have to have a
you have to say what that mean that you
mean by implementation so so this is
just really just we don't know maybe the
easiest way to say is just we don't know
how to implement it but it sounds like a
very unlikely to be to to be able to to
be done
um
um also on the other side on the flip
side for the right works man we are we
are saying that you can implement it
right you can you can in fact so
basically here is saying that you can
effectively use your network to
implement this over SVN but the caveat
is that you still don't know whether you
can optimize the network so it's not the
end-to-end result it's saying that if
you assume you can optimize your network
efficiently and and and up to Global
minimum then you can solve the lysbl but
there is a caveat about whether you can
really computationally solve your
network
um that's something we don't uh we don't
know how to do
like we don't know how to prove
theoretically empirically it sounds like
two you can do it just by creating
research
Okay so
[Applause]
I think this is all I wanted to say
about uh the two layer Network
um next we are going to talk about you
know our goal would be the next goal
would be to prove something about
multiple multiple layering Network and
we need more tools so my plan is to
spend the next 10 minutes to talk about
some of the
uh the tools uh and we need to continue
about the tools next in the next lecture
and then we can talk about how to have
better bounds for multi-layer Network
um
but if there's any questions I can
talk about that
I can answer any questions first
it's a little bit awkward I think I
thought I have 20 minutes but it was
only 10 minutes
um but still I think it's okay we can
we can start with the simple thing
but this will be a kind of like a
at least for the moment it will be a
different mindset we are just thinking
about the tools again
Okay so
Okay so
now we are talking we are getting back
to how do we Bond rather marker
complexity
and and we are
talking about the different type of
tools and
and let's recall
um
um
maybe okay I guess before doing that
maybe let's think about
a function
space view
of the rather marker complexity
so maybe let me write down the rather my
complexity first so this is something
like if you have a function class f
a random account complexity is
this is the empirical random complexity
so if f x is equals to Z1 of C
and let's think about uh
um let's define the following set Q
this is a set of vectors and the vectors
are the outputs of Earth
on these endpoints
so for every function you're going to
have a vector and dimensional vector
and so this is basically the set of
outputs
of f
on the data points 0 up to zero
right these are all the possible outputs
you can you can you can you can go you
can get from applying F on this set of
points
and they are vectors and then you can
rewrite this as as the rather Market
complexity as the following
so you can think of this as you are
looking at all the possible vectors V
and Q
and you look at the inner product of
Sigma with v
or just because this well and sigma V is
really just the sum of
Sigma ivi which is the sum of
Sigma i f z i
this is just rewriting
so
so
um the point here is that
this
this rsf
only
depends on Q
depends on the outputs but for example
but not as opposed to
the
for example the parametrization of f
I mean X mixing what I what I mean here
so for example let's say suppose you
have function of class f which is f of x
is equals to something like sum of theta
i x i
where Theta is in dimension d
and suppose you have another function
class F Prime
which is of the following form say
something like sum of say the I
I'm
writing something
where Theta is in D and W also is prime
mind this is just a weird example just
to demonstrate a point so suppose
suppose you have these two function
clause
and they have different parametrization
they have different parameter space even
right so one has v dimensional parts of
a space and the other has 2D dimensional
parametrical space but these two
functions have the same Q
corresponding Q because they're
the the formula of outputs uh
um are the same because
in some sense you can have a one to one
knife between one a function in capital
F and the function in capital F Prime
because they are just a
um
um like like for every possible output
that can be output by the function f you
can also find the one that can be output
by some function in F Prime
so so so they have the different
parametization but they have the same
functionality in some sense or the same
it's the same family of functions
um and they have the same q and then
that means they have the same random
marker complexity
so so I guess you know I'm just trying
to reinforce this idea that the only
thing that matters is the outputs of the
functions but not how the functions are
represented or parametric
and and this would be useful or kind of
like as a as a general thing
um it's kind of like a change of mindset
right so before you are talking about
the parameters right so what are the
parameters of f how do you describe your
parameters from now on we're gonna get
rid of we are not going to think about
the parameters that much we are more
thinking about the outputs of the
functions
and
and there's a so-called massage lemon
which is actually uh one of the things
you are asked to prove in the homework
um so this letter is saying that if this
Q
right satisfies that
Q is first of all
um so I guess maybe let's say
forever vector v in q
the two Norm of V
over squared n is less than m
so this is the this set of Q contains
only bounded vectors in this sense
by the way this
from now on we're going to do some
things very often just because
[Music]
um
you want to normalize your vector you
measure the vector by the normalizing
the normalized norm so so the norm
itself doesn't matter that much you want
to normalize the norm by the dimension
of the vector
right right
[Music]
right that's right but but I think this
is this is actually a very good question
which I I probably should have talked
about
um
early so
the I think probably I mentioned this a
little bit at some point so
um
one of the nice thing about empirical
radar complexity is that now you are in
this mindset that your zi's are fixed
so you don't have any Randomness in CES
they are just the end points fixed
they're like a Fiverr and and of course
the functions can be changed when you
have a family functions but you don't
have a are changing
the eyes
so that simplifies things a lot in some
sense and so in some sense you can think
of this
even in some sense like a you can think
of the functions the the family of
functions are functions that map zis to
real numbers but not functions that Maps
like Rd to real numbers like you can get
forget about any other points this will
just have Imports and all your functions
can be just represented as an
[Music]
and numbers right which are the outputs
on its Imports
um there's no any other parts you have
to care about that's kind of the beauty
of the rather Mark complex in some sense
very cool
um that's kind of the why it's powerful
because you before the Zs the source of
the randomness but not the randomness
come from the sigma
so so that's why you can fix the eyes
as long as
[Music]
I I think I think you're you're uh the
the
exacting problem is not what like for
the side but you are on the right to in
the right direction so so basically the
right of our complexity depends on
how how complex this step queue is
that's what I'm gonna say and and uh
um and actually the next time you can
see like this I think we have actually
uh mentioned this before so if Q is not
very complex for example if Q is a
finite site
then you have a good value marker
complexity
um and of course you know how do you
measure the complex of Q that's a little
kind of like a
um it's a it's a question that we have
to study but but there are for example
if the queue is fine and then you have a
boundary environment complex that's what
I'm going to write so suppose
so then so
you need two things one is that Q is
fine and the other thing is that Q is
kind of like roughly bounded
and these two things that you have that
this expectation over Sigma
of this this thing which is equivalent
to random micro complexity
is bonded by square root 2 N Square
log
Q
over n
so the side of Q coming to play and I
guess as a Corollary
I think this color is something I have
presented before without a proof
if I've satisfies that
the this function is bounded on this
the eyes in the following sense
the average output is founded by m
Square
the average output square is divided by
m Square then
the random marker complexity of f
is founded by
2 underscore
log
F over
Okay so
so that's the that's the relatively easy
thing where you have final hypothesis
costs
um
[Applause]
all right okay so and and this is a
homework question of myself as a
homework question I think there's the
hint which is actually pretty important
which is you should consider using
something about the moment generating
function which will make the math easier
they actually there are two ways to
prove it another way is that you do
discretization plus Union Bond and that
will give your you will have a
relatively hard time to do that just
because the the constant is still so
hard to to make like you can you can
work out a similar Bond but just a
little nicely the moment generating
function is very really cool
um the proof is actually pretty short if
you use the right way you use it in the
right way okay so I guess uh let me just
briefly um uh give a quick overview of
what we're gonna do next so that you
kind of appreciate why I'm setting up
the things here so so the things the
next thing is that what if Q
Q is not finite
what do we do
right so and our answer would be that
you you do some discretization
and plus uni mode
uh so you have a so basically you have
some have some cover stuff
and then you have a union Bond okay or
maybe I should say I have this
conversation to reduce to
the final case
that's that's basically an idea and you
probably have seen this idea before
right like you have seen it right in the
in the third lecture maybe but when we
talk about uh infinite hypothesis class
but here the difference is that here you
are discredible you are discretizing
the output space the set queue which is
a
um uh n-dimensional a set of
n-dimensional vectors so before you are
discretizing
the the parameter space here you have a
d dimensional parameter space you
describe it has that but here you are
doing a more in substance fundamental
discretization because finally the
parameters as I argued it's probably not
the most important thing right what's
really important is that what's the
functionality of this family functions
so so now your art is quite testing in
the right space
uh a more fundamental space because this
is the space of the outputs
so so what we're going to do is we're
going to discuss a few techniques to
discretize
uh uh this queue and and what kind of
like visualization you really need
um so and so forth so um and and there's
actually some kind of like a pretty
uh deep Theory theorem which is called
the the the changing fit like the The
Dudley changing theorem which actually
required let you to
discrete height in your United States
where you have a hierarchical
discretization so that you can have the
best discretization so this is something
beyond what we have done before uh even
you you don't care about the difference
between the output space and parameter
space here you can discretize in a much
more efficient fashion
um so so that's what we're gonna do next
and then we're gonna use this for the uh
the multilayer network
okay sounds good I think that's all for
today